we
um obviously did a ton of research and
found the top cave safety people on the
planet who are these uh this these uh
slovakian guys
who um they do riggings for i mean any
big stuff that happens in a cave whether
it's a commercial shoot or
um
you know whatever it may be a film shoot
these are the guys that are doing the
rigging so we
you know flew them in they had about a
week to figure out how it is how you
know we could actually get them into the
cave so they built all of these special
harnesses and pulley systems and um you
know at the end of the day they didn't
end up going into that cave as you saw
but you know those were the guys who who
had it all set
i mean lighting in the reconstruction
was a lot easier i mean those those we
actually shot in
um
in hungary and slovakia where they have
kind of very big
um
cavernous
gypsum caves which is the type of cave
that
um that that this was that they actually
survived in the the actual cave as i was
describing a few minutes ago um was just
way too difficult to try to you know we
had scenes with 40 actors and with
children and just kind of getting all of
that in and out of the actual cave was
just never going to happen so we used
these
show caves in
hungary and slovakia that that fit you
know kind of they were they were gypsum
caves so they were you know the the
right type of cave they they also had
the big cavernous rooms you know the
rooms that they had that were in the
original game were massive and we really
wanted to get that
scope in in the reenactments as well
and those caves actually had power in
them like those were show caves where
they take tours and they take
students and schools and all that kind
of stuff in so um
those were relatively easy to bring
equipment in and lighting and all of
that
the cave that we shot in
ukraine their actual cave um i mean you
know just from what i described you
before going down 100 feet you know
going through another 150 feet where it
was all you know basically submerged in
water
um
you know that was
a much bigger challenge so
we needed you know kind of a few huge
generators outside we brought in again
all of these kind of specialty
caving people um specialty caving
lighting people and uh power you know
electric people
um they had to they had to um basically
bring you know kind of hundreds and
hundreds of feet of cable just to get it
into the parts of the cave that we were
shooting in and through water
um so that was a huge challenge it took
about a week just to get power into the
cave all the reenactment stuff again was
done between uh hungary and slovakia so
we did all of the casting in hungary so
i mean the well the well-known actors
were well-known hungarian actors the the
most well-known one was the one who
plays astor sturmer who's a very famous
stage actress in hungary
um but there's there's um fantastic
service companies in hungary i mean
there's just the the production
um the quality of the crews there and
the equipment there and the people there
was
amazing it was fantastic so um you know
we just had uh
a you know the casting agent who does
any feature film that shoots out there
and they brought in yeah a lot of you
know a lot of the kids had never acted
before and
our main concern with
with them was really
um
you know physically
looking enough like the
you know you know the the real survivors
and then you know the like
the the kids once they started like the
21 year olds and obviously esther
sturmer those ones we you know kind of
were working with more um well-known
actors they just had to be a lot more
dynamic
most of those kids were not child actors
actually one of them the kid who plays
um there's two kids you most likely
wouldn't have noticed it because i think
one of them was only in a few scenes but
there's two kids actually that play sam
sturmer who's kind of like the the 14
year old
boy who um you know we kind of shot with
him for a little bit and the other ones
were just kind of really jumping off the
screen and he was he was less so and he
was actually more of a child actor than
the other ones were and then we kind of
switched which switched him out somewhat
early on um and i think you know the
director was just finding that she was
doing
a lot better with the kids who you know
were not kind of these child actor types
weirdly we wanted it to be
optimistic as as gruesome as the time
period was
um and as difficult as you know the
things that they had to go through
they persevered um because of you know
their their strength of character
their sense of family um you know
sticking together
um
and you know just just being strong
throughout not listening to you know
what the majority of people were doing
everybody was going to the ghetto and
they said we're not going to do this and
we're going to stick together as a
family and you could kind of you know
you could see throughout the story how
that was the most important thing to
them was making sure that you know the
family stayed together and i think that
that's really how they
how they made it through